we've got some important information for
couples this morning and it involves
fighting we are looking at how to win a
fight an argument if you will a recent
poll if you're wondering found that
americans fight with their spouse pretty
frequently about 30 of people say that
one or more times per week is normal for
them uh 28 say one or multiple times a
month
and i don't know these people but a
third of people say once or multiple
times per year of course it's not just
couples who get in arguments that's not
many arguments to be honest with you uh
or disagreements uh to help you win any
of them social psychologist heidi grant
is here with tips on how to get it done
and when you should back off and lay
down your arms and agree to disagree so
i was interested to read that you should
not in an argument focus on why you're
right
not right away right it actually turns
out to be that i think probably the
biggest mistake people make in an
argument with anyone we think that the
way we're going to win so so to speak is
to
just sort of pummel the other person
with all the reasons why we're right and
they're wrong and not surprisingly
what's wrong with that right it doesn't
actually work because actually all human
beings get a little defensive about
their beliefs their opinions their
preferences we want to feel like we're
right so it turns out there's a
technique that's really powerful it's
called a two-sided argument you actually
start by why the other person is right
right what's legitimate about your point
of view what's valid what's at least
understandable and if i do that right i
start by validating your perspective it
turns out you're much more open to mine
because it makes people less defensive
and then they can finally hear you right
so if you start by validating the other
person then follow up with why you're
right you're much more likely to
persuade them to come to your side
gail so you say i see why you feel that
way exactly and ideally
and you don't really see why they feel
that way i remember once in marital
counseling the guy says to me gail do
you want peace or do you want to be
right and i said i want both
he said well it doesn't work that way
and so i mean all this sounds really
good but in the heat of battle it's very
hard to validate i think you're
absolutely right and you said something
really important it's the heat of battle
so sometimes when we're going into these
conversations we are feeling a lot of
emotion and so being able to do that
sort of perspective taking where you do
understand where the other person is
coming from is quite hard
one simple thing anyone can do actually
at any time when you're feeling a lot of
strong emotion is what psychologists
call labeling it takes just a moment you
pause and think to yourself what is it
that i'm feeling i'm feeling anxious i'm
feeling angry i'm feeling frustrated i'm
feeling defensive and simply labeling
your emotion there's a lot of research
that shows it kind of brings it down to
a manageable level from there you can
actually think all right am i being fair
to this other person can i take their
perspective have a better conversation
speaking of labeling how do you label a
win what is a winner good question um i
mean i think the win losing frame is a
really bad way to approach any argument
i think really the goal should always be
you know ideally persuading them to
change to your point of view and at
minimum being understood i think often
in a relationship in particular if you
can get to a place where you feel there
was real mutual understanding that's its
own kind of win that has a lot of
lasting positive effects i see a ring on
your finger do you use these techniques
i do indeed um i'm sure my husband is
watching right now
and it's funny you know one of the
things that we just actually had this is
throwing shoes at the tv you may be
actually wondering now why i have said a
few things oh i have no
90 grand she'll be home we'll be right
back thank you for being here